six times a year these giants battle
each other for top placement in Japan's
most beloved traditional sport soon
highly visualized this sport dates back
more than a thousand years originating
as a right of the Shinto religion
matches are a true window into an
earlier era participants wear colorful
Shinto Gaara
stomping drives evil spirits from the
ring while tossing sacred salt appeases
the Shinto gods before the ring is
sullied by the Restless peasants what's
surprising about sumo is the sheer size
of the wrestlers a traditional diet that
includes choco lava a stew made from
fatty meats cabbage eggs and bean
sprouts helps them bulk up entering the
ring girth is advantageous
the rules are simple knock your opponent
down or out of the ring
wrestler slam slap and toss opponents
into submission it usually lasts less
than a minute sumo wrestlers belong to
stables which function like clubs and
are where they learn the finer points of
single from experienced mentors each
match is an opportunity for sumo
wrestlers to move up the complex ranking
system or down at the top are the
Yokozuna or Grand Champions in the ring
they are distinguished by the large
ropes around their waists a match like
this is a feast for the fans
but no matter what they're read the
stylized battle these giants lies the
heart of Japanese tradition